vilnius la capitale de la lituanie a mis
des années pour devenir une des
destinations prisées d'europe de l'est
pour promouvoir son petit centre
historique classé parmi les secours
elle avait lancé des campagnes
publicitaires mondiales comme celle ci
aussi audacieuse qu'efficace il était
s'annonçait donc lorieux jusqu'à ce que
le dire s'invite à la fête et impose
deux mètres de distance
le maire de la ville fidèle à sa
réputation a décidé d'innover une fois
de plus est cette fois en un temps
record notre cameraman l'a rencontré au
coeur d'une ville qui est en train de se
transformer en immense café à ciel
ouvert plus de 200 restaurateurs sont
déjà inscrits aux programmes émanent
tous tous pk a sauté sur l'occasion
il croit des gens qu'il va éviter la
faillite il pourra non seulement
incluses et le trottoir gratuitement
mais ce n'aurait pas été assez
il pourra aussi installer dix tables
dans ce petit parc et mamie servir de
l'alcool
la règle s'applique à tous en notant que
l'espace récupéré soit pas plus loin que
40 mètres du restaurant le tout sur tout
sans les dédales administratifs habituel
titi et déjà les clients à bon
lèvres after des spurs bref c'est une
flexibilité qui devrait dans l'urgence
inspiré des villes comme montréal selon
l'urbaniste gérard bulls ce soit des
situations comme ça convient que les
avancées se font de manière plus
significative parce qu'effectivement il
ya moins de capacité de résistance la
preuve c'est qu'en quelques jours dans
son propre quartier de heureusement on a
pour la première fois élargi l'espace
pitot on sent que personne ne rouspète
faut qu'on apprenne à faire des choses
plus simplement plus notre essayons de
voir quelle sont tous les morceaux de
terre et dans le domaine public dans le
domaine privé qu'on peut ré approprier
collectivement c'est une belle
opportunité jetables pour expérimenter
des choses présentement
quand il n'y a pas que les rues les
parcs que l'on peut emprunter
voici à quoi ressemble l aéroport
international de vilnius
dimanche après-midi le tablier a été
transformé en ciné parc e géant une
première mondiale est une initiative des
organisateurs du festival des films qui
a dû être annulé tout comme les voyages
la ville a aussi distribué l'équivalent
en 2 millions de dollars en certificats
cadeaux aux travailleurs de la santé
pour qu'ils profitent aussi de cette
petite renaissance culturelle et sociale
or l'art de se réinventer en temps de
pandémie si trouver l'équilibré entre la
sécurité la qualité de vie dit le maire
mais sans jamais jamais perdre de vue le
danger qui nous guette ici tamar altérer
ce coup radio canada montréal